david les parlementaires sont plutôt
réfractaire à ce nouvel allongement de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire de trois mois
et demi les facteurs c'est le terme
exact sophie mais c'est en tout cas la
volonté est de la majorité l'état
d'urgence sanitaire devrait durer
jusqu'au mois de juin puisque le
parlement s'apprête à donner son feu
vert
cet après midi une pâte une petite
partie à des députés de la majorité est
contre
pour ce qui est de l'opposition cette
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire est un nouvel affront à la
liberté fondamentale est coupée c'est un
problème d'être en perpétuel état
d'exception l'état d'urgence et un état
d'exception dans lequel un moment donné
le poids de l'exécutif prend le pas sur
sur d'autres d'autres pouvoirs et c'est
un problème
voilà je pense qu'on pouvait très bien
se passer de ça ou au moins un minimum
que l'on leur nouvelle chaque mois voilà
et là ça sera pas le cas donc on s'y
opposer il ya de plus en plus de
françaises et français qui se rendent
dans une situation difficile
d'un point de vue économique social avec
une détresse étudiante qui est de plus
en plus présente dans notre pays et donc
il faut être au rendez-vous de cette
exigence
le gouvernement a présenté va présenter
progressivement un plan pour l'égalité
des chances présent la république va se
déplacer sur différents thèmes dans les
jours à venir et donc il faut absolument
soutenir cette politique avec beaucoup
de vigueur mais elle trouve que la
lettre de mes collègues est tout à fait
valable soulève des points qui sont
justes et qui mérite d'être étudiée il
faut le faire de concert avec le
gouvernement moi fut convaincu qu'ils
auront une oreille attentive sur ces
propositions de la part de matignon on
tempère du côté de la république en
marche avec des propositions a créé en
mars 2020 pour rappel ce régime boîte à
outil permet d'instaurer toutes les
mesures telles que le couvre-feu actuel
ou encore la fermeture des restaurants
réinstaurer depuis le 17 octobre dernier
le parlement l'a prorogé jusqu'au 16
février prochain d'où la nécessité de ce
vote tous les groupes politiques de
l'assemblée or majorité ont annoncé un
vote contre ce nouvel allongement
de trois mois et demi principal argument
la lassitude de la population et le
ras-le-bol des restaurateurs station de
ski ou bien encore des étudiants est les
menaces de désobéissance civile font
également partie des raisons évoquées à
gauche comme à droite on déniche une
banalisation de ce régime assez
particulier merci beaucoup david kelly
fait en direct du palais bourbon